Here is Marla,
we already know her story.
Many chronic diseases leading
to many medications and
many encounters with
the healthcare system.
As a result,
her chart is large and complex.
And should she visit her PCP,
if she had one, they would need a quick
overview of it to adequately plan
the visit and her comprehensive care.
Her friend Doris on the left
works out regularly and
rarely goes to her physician.
Today she's visiting because
she overdid things a bit and
sprained her right knee.
Doris' chart is thin, and there's
really not much else for her PCP to be
concerned with, other than any routine
preventive care that might be due.